we should be able to have that over to
you by Monday
yeah no problem thank you
what the hell is this oh this is not
mega-desk
no it's not they call it quad desk
that's ridiculous this is made up of
three desks oh my god we're gonna have
to rename and then aren't we I love
Dwight Schrute dam was in our file I
have to reboot again hey do I do you
want an Altoid what do you think in
school we learned about this scientist
who trained dogs to salivate at the
sound of a bell by feeding them whenever
a bell rang so for the past couple weeks
I've been conducting a similar
experiment right okay I'll tone sure
ain't white bin pre yes what are you
doing
I
what I don't know mom my mouth tastes so
bad all of a sudden Jim what's up buddy
this is not funny why is my stuff in
here well it's weird
ooh daughter first a boy that's pretty
good yeah well I'm not paying for my own
stuff okay I know you did this because
you're friends with the ending machine
guy Oh Steve yeah oh no no no that's my
pencil cup I don't think so I think so
and you're gonna hand it over to me I
love these okay Oh notice
jae-won care you know how many against
nickels where is my desk that is weird
this is not funny this is totally
unprofessional okay well you're the one
who lost the desk didn't lose my desk
okay calm down where was the last place
you saw okay who moved my desk I think
you should retrace your steps okay I am
going to tell Michael and this entire
office will be punished colder warmer a
little warmer Hey ooh
warmer warmer warmer warmer warmer cold
cold cold
back up
Dwight Schrute
hi um what sort of discounts are we
giving on the G I'm giving you this
information like 20 times by the ream
things now 978 sorry it's a disc a 7%
okay thank you gotta get back to work
wash your hands Kevin who are you faxing
so early in the morning
oh um Anna who explained I don't have a
ton of contact with this Grandin branch
but before I left I took a box of
Dwight's stationery so from time to time
I send Dwight faxes from himself from
the future
Dwight at 8 a.m. today someone poisons
the coffee do not drink the coffee more
instructions will follow cordially
future Dwight you'll thank me later
I'm sorry I had no idea no it's it's
okay okay oh my god oh my god no never
okay this is it in the end the greatest
snowball isn't a snowball at all it's
fear Merry Christmas
hope this helps
what are you doing Shh be scared
it works
what is this
happy holidays the way but do not open
it till Christmas you're so pathetic how
long did this take you three hours five
minutes actually I am a black belt in
gift wrapping yeah
no such thing you don't give out black
belts for things that are stupid well I
hope it was worth it because I'm gonna
take it apart in about five minutes I
think I'll take a little bit longer than
that really if I can skin a mule deer in
less than 10 minutes I ought to be able
to cut my morning Dwight who are you who
am i i am jim we've been working
together for 12 years
we're joke Dwight you're not Jim Jim's
not Asian you seriously never noticed
hey
that's off to you for not seeing race
alright then Jim why don't you tell me
about that sale that you made yesterday
wellington systems sold them ten cases
of 24-pound lighter stock or were you
talking about Quaker Murphy because I
didn't close that one yet but I'm hoping
I've got a voicemail from Paul Krieger
waiting for me
you have one new message
no no no no that is sensitive
information only for employees not
Outsiders white cut it out I'm trying to
work you don't work here you're not Jim
Jim I got us that dinner reservation
great go 7:30 oh great can't wait
Jim's at the dentist this morning and
Steve is an actor friend of ours I don't
know who you are but you are not Jim
this is Jim
how do oh how didn't
it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best that's a
ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollar you
know what imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery so I thank you energy
theft is not a joke Jim millions of
families suffer every year Michael oh
that's funny Michael
you